hey everyone
how are we all doing really awesome to
be down this uh end of the country i
have to
admit i've actually never been to
manheim before but i was really excited
to get the opportunity to kind of
finally come down and see what is
happening here especially with the
community because i meet so many of you
folks
when you come up to berlin so i felt
like it's only fair to come down and see
where you're all based and what you're
all doing
so today i want to also talk with you
all as
alex mentioned i'm working in the sector
of looking at how we can make climate
action happen
through our tech products so i really
want to talk about how we can support
climate action
with online activities so some of the
things we do every day like
searching for
cakes and
maybe for some coding solutions um i i
just read on the stack overflow a lot of
people spend a lot of time looking up uh
solutions um
and also i want to talk about the data
that powers that and kind of maybe
what's kind of missing and what the
challenges are that we're facing as well
at kosher and maybe you are too
so first of all i wanted to get an idea
of how many folks in the room are
technologists like working within the
tech sector
so not surprising pretty much everyone
right
um and who is working on something that
they would consider a solution for the
current climate crisis
a few less quite a few less
um so very interesting uh who's working
at a company who has some sort of public
pledge
of what the company is going to do
towards the current climate crisis
a few more that's great okay so we're
getting there
um and yeah i think you might be getting
the point that i'm trying to make um
because the thing is we just we can't
wait for some
miracle climate tech solution that's
going to save us all um unfortunately we
are already at the crossroads
we already need to make very hard
decisions about what we're doing so that
we can secure a livable future um not
just for our great children
great-grandchildren or
great-great-grandchildren but also for
our children and for ourselves
um it's really that soon and we actually
have the tools and we have the know-how
for us to be able to limit the warming
that we're seeing um scientifically
but we really aren't leaning into
making it happen
so this is from the ipcc report
and it was interesting that this most
latest report actually called out
technology for the first time and first
of all for the impact that technology is
having
um on the climate but also about the
possibilities that technology give us um
that maybe we didn't have access to
previously
so just to introduce myself i'm jessica
green i use she her pronouns
i'm at sleepy pioneer on twitter and
most of the platforms like github etc
i'm a software engineer at kosher as
alex mentioned and as he also mentioned
i'm also a community leader with pi
ladies berlin
and i just wanted to share with you a
little bit about who i am and why i got
into this sector or how i got into this
sector so i'm a career changer
i used to work in film production that
was what i studied then i got into
specialty coffee and was a coffee
roaster which was a very great
opportunity to also see firsthand
a lot of the effects of climate change
because it is affecting a lot of
the places where coffee grows which as
we know is predominantly the global
south
and also having an impact on that
industry directly
i switched into tech in 2017 2018
and it was immediately clear to me that
as well as switching into a different
sector or a different domain of work i
really wanted to switch into somewhere
that i would be able to contribute
something that would be doing
something towards the climate crisis
that we're facing
so that's a little bit about me
and what i want to talk about today like
this is kind of like the general rundown
of the topics i'm going to bring up is
kind of the responsibility of tech
companies and professionals in the
climate crisis so us
and a kosher's
mission
to support people to take more
sustainable actions online and i hope it
doesn't come across as too much of a
sales pitch i really just want to share
with you like our approach but it is
only a approach there's many different
ways and we need different ways to uh
kind of tackle this i also want to talk
a bit about like the data because we're
pi data right so we're probably most of
us in the room are interested in data in
one form or another
and the challenges that we're facing
there
and then last of all because i don't
want to leave it on a negative note i'm
i want to talk about what we maybe can
all do to work towards a better planet
and so
something hopefully
you're all feeling rather positive at
the end and not too negative for the bbq
layer
so yeah i mentioned earlier we're in a
climate crisis and the thing is we're
largely in that crisis because we keep
bringing keep burning sorry fossil fuels
instead of finding a path of them and we
know we have some paths we have some
ideas of how we might do that we're just
not doing it we're choosing not to do it
so that's a problem
and i think one of the things that we
don't have a good grasp of is
understanding responsibility
for
why that is so
it's kind of
easy enough maybe for us to say like hey
our servers run on renewable energy
but what if you're relying on aws as
your cloud provider or a
google cloud platform where what are
they running on or
you know what where are the other
sources of where this coming from so
often this is broken up into different
scopes and like the first scope will be
like kind of their emissions from
burning fossil fuels directly to make
your product
um and the second one will be around
emissions from electricity
so like things for running your products
maybe even running the office that you
also in is that renewable energy
or is that using fossil fuels
and then we have emissions from activity
in our supply chain so i already
mentioned like cloud computing
um there are today
some ways to see what your carbon output
is or your carbon emissions are for
where your code is running but they're
not always fully transparent or complete
um so these are things that we don't
always know the answer to
but i think they're really important
things for us to think about
and i think if we want to go even
further
how responsible are we for our users
carbon decisions as well
so if we're creating tech products that
encourage people to buy lots of new
products every day or every week
that's carbon emissions
are we responsible for that
even if it's their decision
but we built the platform
so i think this is something really
interesting for us to all think about
and to think about in terms of our
product unfortunately the thing is that
current business models either don't
recognize that carbon responsibility
or they pass it on to other people
so it could be that you like update to
more efficient machines which means that
you're not emitting as much carbon but
then you've dumped all of the old
machines that you were using in a tip
which means
that there's all that waste been created
this is complex and this is something
i'm trying to get my head around and i'm
sure there's some of you in the room
maybe a foot about it you maybe have
lots of ideas around this i'd love to
hear them so i'm really
trying to start conversation more than
anything
but i think these are really interesting
challenges for us to think about
especially as we're building lots of
products and we're also building lots of
products with lots of data
so that data has to live somewhere that
data gets processed somewhere
this is all really relevant for us as
technologists
so a kojo so it sounded like a lot of
people have already heard about a kosher
so i have this in for the people that
didn't raise their hand earlier and so
kurt kozia is a search engine
and we are doing a search for about a
planet so you browse online and then we
help the fight on the ground so mainly
through planting trees um around eighty
percent of our profits go to planting
trees but a hundred percent of our
profits actually go to a better planet
it's a steward owned company money
cannot be taken out of it we don't have
investors and this is our mission and
everything we're doing is kind of like
with that value in mind
um yes sorry as i mentioned we use 100
of the profits for the planet
and the trees that we plan we also
protect we do it with local communities
because while a lot of us in the company
are technologist specialists
we're not agricultural specialists so we
work with people who are within the
communities where the trees are being
planted this is really important not
only because they're the people with the
knowledge of how to best do this but
also if the trees are going to stay
there and have long-term survival
it's really necessary
that the people there have the
opportunity to work on this and they
just simply know best
so this number is always going up
but this is the trees planted by the
kosher community
so we have 15 million people currently
using acosia
and um we're involved in 35 different
countries for tree planting and that's
60 plus active projects
and as i mentioned what we're standing
for is like profits for the planet so
something everybody does every bit every
day almost
uh privacy
um we go beyond neutral so we have not
just carbon negative but we're also so
not just carbon neutral we're carbon
negative so if you make a search with us
we're actually
taking carbon out of the
out of the air um and we're trying to be
really radically transparent so
talking about stuff like this and simply
put yeah we believe that saving our
world shouldn't cost you the earth so
we're integrating a positive impact into
your everyday actions and the stuff
you're gonna do anyway like browse the
internet shop online and so much more
and as i mentioned we think being
neutral is no longer enough so we're
sharing the power to be climate active
what that means is we realize that it's
great if we're doing that but we also
need to pass on that empowerment to the
people that use our product to also be
able to make more sustainable choices
and to be climate active in their
everyday lives
and as i mentioned this isn't meant to
be really a big sales pitch uh hopefully
you don't feel that way it's just a way
of like approaching this um that i feel
is really well done there's many other
examples out there as well
the other thing we're doing is calling
out green washing and really trying to
help people make sustainable choices so
identifying the biggest polluters is not
always evident we know that search
engines are not neutral um they are all
search engine indexes have some bias
within them that's the way it works
because uh they work on looking at
historical logs or it's about like who's
able to put better ceo on their website
we see bias for many many different ways
most search engines work on a model of
advertisement that means that people who
pay will have their result at the top
um so you know i think at this time at
this point
we all need to acknowledge that search
is not neutral um but that doesn't mean
that it can't be an experience that does
something good for the world and helps
us to make more sustainable choices
and these are some of the ways we're
doing that so the green leaf that you
can see at the top it's a little icon
next to the search domain or the little
fossil fuel icon give people an
indication of the kind of domains
um that are in our search results or we
can show the impact for example for
germany or another country and kind of
really give you this information but in
a passive way
throughout your journey on the search
engine so this isn't intrusive to your
experience isn't something you have to
click off and go on to a new page for
this is something you can see
within the uh user journey that you're
already taking
and recently we introduced shopping
and we have this uh highlighted group of
results at the top uh which are all
sustainable products and they're fed
from a database that we're currently
building which i'm going to talk a
little bit more about
so where's the data
right you're like oh that looks nice um
and we just rebranded and it does look
nice i don't work in front end uh so i
definitely can't take any credit for
that whatsoever but it does look kind of
cool um but yeah we're we're mostly
interested in data so let's talk about
where the data is so
we're looking predominantly at outside
sources to certify
and we're kind of currently looking as i
showed you for light products so we're
trying to kind of go around this thing
if like someone wants to buy something
can we show them a more sustainable
alternative so instead of maybe buying
the adidas sneakers they maybe buy the
vega sneakers or
um instead of buying an iphone maybe
they buy a fair phone
so one way we're looking at this is like
how we can split up and how we can
collect data around different types of
sustainability information and even
finding what's out there
and this is where the challenges really
come in so collecting cleaning and
understanding data in this field is
currently
super time consuming and is actually
just something that requires experts in
the domain um because
you know you might be thinking like oh
well it has a fair trade label so
therefore it's good right
but the thing is
i used to work in coffee
and fair trade while being a really
great initiative is more like an
insurance policy where it ensures that
coffee produces earn some money
even if the conditions of a harvest are
bad
whereas if you buy direct trade coffee
that farmer or producer may actually
have been able to earn more money that
way
and i really think it comes down to your
definition of fair which is kind of
hard to measure in an objective manner
so a lot of the problems that we find is
like just too few items even have the
sustainability information
and then as i mentioned like not all
labels are standardized and they can
mean different things
for clothing there's very many different
tech summaries out there so it's not
very easy to map and put into one
database
and to be able to say like this product
ranks above this one
and also a lot of these data sources
require a lot of cleaning
we're not an incredibly big company and
our team alone is only i think four or
five people
with two people very dedicated to
working on this um so it's really too
much work for us
alone
so we have a partnership also with some
domain experts from the bht which is the
berliner hoshula for technic and the
technician tu which is the technical
university
and we're working on this project called
the green consumption assistant so i
really recommend checking this out if
this is interesting to you
this website is completely in german um
currently i i'm not sure if it's going
to be translated into english
but it explains there what we're trying
to do and it's a five-year project to
try and create solutions like the ones
i'm talking about
and one of those solutions is the green
database so this is an open data set
um and it's currently what fuels the
occasional shopping vertical which is
what i showed you earlier you can check
it out on github it's still in progress
so please don't go there and
expect it to be like this super shiny
completely finished thing we're working
on it a lot but it's still a work in
progress
and i think this is really interesting
because this is really our first
technique into thinking about how we can
build a data source
to really be able to rank and put and
boost these kind of results into our
search results
but we need to go further than that
so it's okay if we have a data bank but
that will of course as you probably know
if you work with data require a lot of
updating
especially fashion goes out of season
really really quick
so we really have to ensure that things
are moving quickly and automated because
of this
but one of our goals is actually to add
these sustainability labels as a
standard to the schemas
for the products
that are on this schema.org
and i think this is a really good
approach and this is something we can
maybe all think about and maybe those
things you also know in your own work
where you can actually build this into
the standards so like
another idea i've heard about would be
to have a co
like a carbon.txt like a robot.txt on
websites
that lists some of the things that that
website is trying to do for the climate
these are small solutions but these are
things that kind of make sure
it's built in from the start and then we
have the data and we can go and build
products on top of it
so
i promised try end more positive and
like what can we do i think things that
you can do are support advocating for
sustainable software where you work
so you can think about what that means
there's lots of great websites like
climate.tech is a great resource for
finding out about how you can make your
infra more sustainable how you can do
more sustainable web dev
you'll also find jobs on there if you're
interested in moving into the sector
but maybe you can also apply small
things in the company where you're
working so instead of using a glossy
paper in the printer you can use
recycled paper or recycled toilet paper
for example
you can switch to a closure so there's a
sales pitch
and if you're really really stuck
because i know that this is often a
problem you can use hashtag g at the end
and it will take you to google
you can follow the gca project which is
what i mentioned and support us to make
these standards better and more
transparent and i really welcome
everyone to go check out
follow the project on github and like i
said it's not complete but
you can follow it and see what you can
do to maybe get involved as well
and we can't do it alone so i read these
results on stack overflow while i was on
the train here from berlin and i have to
be honest i was really really upset
and disappointed that still in 2022
uh we just like i mean you can't barely
read this graphic and i apologize but
it's um split by gender
of people that work as technologists
and it's 91.88
men
and then
a breakdown of like women and non-binary
um preferring not to say and other
we also see that it's predominantly in
the northern hemisphere where the
biggest impacts of climate change are
not yet seen
that are also working in the sector so i
think it's really really important
that we start involving more people in
this conversation as well
we have a responsibility because we're
the biggest groups in this but we also
need to make sure that we're looking for
the other voices to support us with this
work
so
thank you very much first of all for
listening i hope that this sparked some
interest and maybe you want to talk
about it over a burger or i'm not sure
what is on the barbecue today some veg
everything
uh vegan options
but if you do have questions you want to
reach out to me and connect you can
reach out to me on linkedin you can
write me on twitter i would love to hear
from you i would love to hear your
thoughts on this so thank you very much
you